I Lost Danya. I keep clicking these viruses because I keep downloading. Hello. Are you here? Yeah, I'm here. I'm here
I thought I lost you. I I don't know what happened. Okay
You never drink any water is it because you're a robot? No. No, I have like two beverages on my desk
soda
Not good for you. No soda. No, this is sparkling water
I I almost never drink. I love soda. Like I love root beer and stuff, but I almost never do it
Okay now last time we sort of focused primarily on handling past pawns I tortured you with some very tactical end games
Today we're gonna do kind of a mix
We're gonna start with a really cool warm-up study. That's kind of mind-blowing and one of my favorites
This should be famous but isn't then we're going to focus today a little bit more on
Concepts and kind of developing conceptual thinking so it won't be quite as tactically torturous
Although there will still be a lot of things to calculate and hopefully it'll be fun
Yes, sir
It will be fun
Yes all aboard. Okay. So this is a study by the Sarich of brothers from the 1920s. It's white to play and draw
And white is going forward. So c8 equals queen is possible in this position
Okay. Oh, I see. But the issue is that the bishop's gonna come pin us. Oh, could you let me make arrows?
Awesome. Okay. So yeah, like johnny said we can promote in a move
But he will just pin us and then we will be just two behind
This pawn and then we can't stop him. He'll push. He's unstoppable. Just like us in the streamer awards
Or if you want to troll or if you want to troll go b6
That's true. We would troll a little bit. Yeah
Um good
So, okay
I will think I will think and you should enjoy your taboo late. I will think as long as you need no rush at all
Yeah, if you could think aloud that uh
What about okay, let's just came to my head the problem is that the bishops comes here
So what if we just did this? Um preventing it
He would probably defend it with his king with this guy
So he would probably bring this guy here or here
Maybe it's better to bring the king towards my king towards the opposition. So I would guess maybe e4 is better
And now this is still a threat
So now we think
Um, let's see, so we still can't push
Um, there's really no way to prevent that
Um, there's nothing we could promote we can never get it in check
To move the king. Oh, we're supposed to draw. We're not looking for a win, right? So looking for a draw
Well, this might just not be it. This this is just the end of the line and it probably just doesn't work
Yeah, can you six king e4 loses and I could show this on the board?
uh because
at this point black simply pre moves bishop f5 and
You know, we're back to square zero and process of elimination is actually a super powerful tool in a lot of endgames
Because it it forces you to consider moves that may appear totally illogical
And that's going to be one of the themes of today's lesson is essentially
Forcing yourself to look at everything even stuff that seems self-evidently bad
So anything I was of that nature here
Okay, my second thought is well, how else can you get the king to stop this pawn?
You can't go this way. So if this is too slow, but the idea would be d6 c5 and then
B6 it might be too slow
But if I did this
And he i'm not gonna make them actually i'll make this if I did this and he pushed we would be able to stop him
So he's not gonna push. So
Well black has to play bishop black has to play bishop f5 to stop the c-pawn
Yeah
Stopping the pawn now king c5
Continue the plan
continue the plan
black for example
Plays bishop c8
Defending right and the problem that you're going to run into is that here i'm going to start moving my king back and every time
You slip to a7. I immediately start pushing b5
Gotcha, so this does not work and if you chill out chill on b6
Then black will eventually, you know shoulder your king and win the c7 pawn. I hate when we get shouldered
Yeah, incredibly annoying principle. I'll you wouldn't know anything about that. Would you?
boxing
Never done that
Would you ever do chess boxing dania?
Nah, I think that's i've been going out of my comfort zone more more and more in the last couple years, but I i'm
I'm, just curious. What what does that mean going out of your comfort zone? Hey, i've been dancing on stream
Stream. Ah, you know these toxic these toxic streamers beat me in a match and then they made me dance. I mean
Can you believe that? I don't even know if it was you because the face didn't make it into the video. It was just
Fraction of your body
so we don't really know if you did the punishment or not for daniel narutiski to dance in front of a public is
You you have to understand how much this year has been big for you. That's fair. Maybe we'll make you box next year
Well, we'll see about that
Process of elimination is taking place. What have we eliminated? Well king e6 king d6 eliminated c8 queen eliminated
Now is the part where you have to consider the absurd moves. So what move appears like the most absurd possible move white could play?
Like king e8
Even more absurd than that the most counterproductive move
Count uh, it gets worse than king
King, uh, king d. Oh king c8 c8 seems like the worst
In front of your pawn and you're forcing black's pawn forward. What could be more illogical than that move, right? Yes
Yes now black pushes the pawn two squares because if black defends it with their bishop then you play one move and draw immediately
We play a king b8 attacking the pawn and if they defend we could win it and draw very good
Otherwise black loses because you promote so black plays in the initial position the move b5
Now the beauty of the study is revealed. This is a pretty mind-blowing concept
So it appears self-evident that we're going to move our king black is going to stop our pawn, right?
And that's it. We're not going to be in time to stop black's pawn
But here the ready the ready concept as I like to call it comes in handy
The ready good thing. I've never played the ready. So one idea I had
Was well, is there any stalemate possibilities? We get the king to eight there isn't so that's not it
Um, I mean this guy's just gonna push obviously as soon as we move the king the bishops coming here to prevent this, right?
um
Bing
Oh, no, it doesn't work
I was thinking like okay anywhere here. He just plays this. What if we tried this?
I was a bit looking at maybe king b7 coming somehow
So keep calculating the pawn so king here here king here he pushes
Now you need to do the same thing, but you need to somehow win a tempo with your king
How do you win a tempo? Well, there's only one way to win a tempo. You need to attack the bishop
No, I didn't have it I had a moment but it wasn't right
Attack the bishop. So king c7 is correct bring the king towards e5
Exactly here here black checks you
Okay, yep king d6 black pushes
Black pushes oh, they're the critical move exactly
And then we attacked bishop and then as magnus recently learned we can enter the square
Exactly. Yeah, I also feel like i'd never use this square. Yes
Yes, we beat magnus
Yeah, that was that was fun before and
Was it on the stream with you that magnus said he doesn't did he say he doesn't know the rule of this or like he?
Doesn't use the rule of the square. Oh
The joke see I as I learned with you dania, you really just don't consume any chess content
Alex has been we've been posting a lot of shorts on youtube like educational ones
And alex has just been pumping out all the educational chess shorts like the rule of the square
And and alex was playing him in a match and he said thanks alex without your video. I wouldn't have known it
Wow while she in the time odds match, but you need a we need a real education of chess memes. It would be good for you
To do it. Dania learns chess means I can teach you my culture and you can teach me how to play chess
That sounds like a deal
Um, and then you'll teach me chess boxing, you know, yes
I want i'll be next year after me into that world out of your comfort zone
So just to tie up the study king e5 attacks the bishop and i'll show you why I call it the ready
uh concept the bishop has to move because b3
You take the bishop and you promote and after the bishop moves no matter where it moves
What are you going to do here?
We get square
And if I try to stop you
Then what's the prettiest way to draw excellent
bang
And now it's ours
It's ours for the taking that is how I trust but the craziest thing just to me is the solution involves
Literally wasting a tempo and forcing the pawn forward
And the mat like the logical reason why is that when the pawn's on b7 you like you can't approach it with your king
Yep
So so you have to get the tempo attacking the bishop and I have a question for you
Yeah, so like the way you solve these are like really abstract solutions that I don't feel like really any patterns
so I guess kind of like the similar theme in all of your puzzles like they're all just
Problem solving like trying to be creative when it comes solutions
But yeah, like how would you describe stuff from this thought process that you can use going forward into other puzzles?
Yeah, well, I mean first of all, I think i'm going to show you why I call it the ready concept
And I think that the truth of the matter is that end games actually do subject themselves to logic
And this is going to be the theme of the subsequent exercises that I give you
This is more of just sort of a cool warm-up study
But what I kind of want you to draw your attention to is the fact that
You know a lot of physicians they seem very overwhelming and it seems like there's no pattern
There's no pattern, but you can often by making you know incisive observations. You can often guide yourself
Logically to a move that just when you see the move without any explanation may just seem like some sort of computer move or
Something illogical, but in fact, there's often like a hidden logic
To even complicated ideas in the end game. So here for example, that pattern is
Stems from this study. You've probably seen this before
so
Let's see if you see that. Sure I have. Papa Bo says tell me all the end games
and this is very hard ready and this is a super like
Important end game position. So it's white to play and draw
And you'll pick up on the similarity between this and the study. We just did very quickly
So white to play and draw black is going this way
Immediately i'm thinking
We want to bring the king somehow this way so that we're threatening both to get in the square and to defend her pawn
exactly, so
We go diagonally. Go ahead
Papa botes actually didn't show me this one. This is the the ready one you were saying or no, this is the ready study
Yeah
Why is it called ready? Oh, it's because it was composed by rehard ready who of of you know ready fame
Uh, and if h3
And now i'm trying to come no no no you have to be careful, yeah
Um, bing bing
Oh, oh
you're actually
Yeah, you play here and then here you need access to the d7 square to roll out the red carpet for the pawn
And if of course I go king b6 now the second part
of this concept
Um king here
Because if you take that i'm in the square and if you push then I defend like this exactly king here
If you take king f4 if h3 king d6 h2 and finish it off
Nice. Oh
king first
Careful. No, no. No. Oh my god. I'm not even thinking. Okay. Yeah, we push
We only bring the king if we need to exactly king b7 and king d7 with a draw and king
So you can spot the the similarity where you basically multitask, right?
You support your pawn or you you win a tempo essentially and use that tempo to stop your opponent's pass pawn
Got it
Got it. Yep. So, okay
right, so if you're like familiar with
That's the concept that uh stems from that position
but you're right like obviously is this super common in actual tournament practice not really but this was more of a
Tactical warm-up now. We're going to consider a couple of positions where I think we will be able to
Uh derive specific concepts and actionable tips based on those positions. Okay, so I mean even these I mean
this type of concept when it comes to problem solving i'm sure you would use it because
sometimes you meet a position that you think you're completely losing like how far away the king is from the pawn you just have to
Think a little more out of the box. Yeah, and i'm sure there's stuff that applies it more generally
I think if you solve a ton of endgame studies
You just sort of develop the abstract ability to find endgame tactics and endgame tactics are like one of the most difficult
Aspects of chess in general because I think your brain just sort of automatically assumes that with very few pieces left on the board
There's no tactical potential but that could not be further from the truth. That's actually a super important aspect of endgame mastery
There's so many tricks in the endgame
So let's start with a pretty simple position, but an instructive one. Nonetheless
This is from the pro chess league from the last week of the pro chess league
Ah, are you playing in that?
I am unfortunately
My team has lost the first two weeks
So we are one strike away from losing
So that's so the first week we played magnus's team. We play the canada chess for us. That's a good reason
But we were so freaking close. We lost by one point. Um, and it was right there
Uh, it's everybody plays everybody. So I played magnus
A wonder who's on our team, you know, I won early
He was just killing magnus. It was completely winning had he won that game. We would have won the match but
When you're winning against magnus, you know how you feel. It's just your hands shake and your brain stops working
So that was unfortunate
Was unfortunate
Then second week we all played terribly and lost
to brazil
we
I don't know why but brazil is only the whenever I get chess.com challenges from brazil
Just I get extra motivation because we've been farmed by them so many times. Yeah. No those their gms are so strong chess.com players
Yeah, no for sure. It was same thing at the gm level. So we lost and yeah
We're one strike away from getting knocked out, but we're still gonna fight
um
But if you win you guys are still in
If we win we're still in yeah three strikes in your and you're out of the regular season
Well, you know if you need some extra backup i'd happily play for the team if you guys need I appreciate it
We might cross the finish line. I beat a couple 2700s, you know on demand
Yep with well with your newly acquired endgame knowledge. I don't think anybody stands a chance
Yes, this is a simple position again
But a good illustration of an incredibly important endgame principle that applies across almost all endgames
So it is black to play just looking at this kind of abstractly
Sorry white plays king e5 and here it's black to play who is playing for a win here. Just intuitively
white
Clearly what factors can you identify that guide your intuition in that regard face the king is more advanced
They're in black's half of the board
and their pawns on the uh
On the left side of the board are more dense. Well, I guess actually
And and in terms of the bishop placement and the targets only black has a target what is that target
The f7 pawn the f7 pawn exactly. So here's the principle and this is essentially two principles
Packaged into one when you're on the defending side of an endgame any endgame
Your kind of default approach should be to do nothing. The first question you should ask yourself is what happens if I do nothing?
And only if you've identified a specific winning plan for your opponent
Should you be looking for active counter play and even more importantly in the endgame?
You should always avoid unnecessary pawn advances
You should only push a pawn if there is a super compelling reason to do that pushing a pawn in order to create a threat
Is often a trap
Uh that causes more weaknesses to be created and gives your hands your opponent kind of the winning plan
So let's apply that to this position. How would you go about defending this with black?
Yeah, well the first question is if we did nothing, what would white's plan be?
um
I i'm trying to think if there's any way they could break through like
could they
Break through here. I don't think this is a threat
Um, the king just can't enter any other way
So and even if they brought the king over here to defend then we would gain the space
so
It feels like the only way white would pass is if I give them an entry point thrown in these three squares for the king
And then
Should we push any pawns? Wait, sorry. What was the question about pushing the pawn? So what would you just more open-ended?
What would you play with black here?
uh
Let's see. I don't want to move my I'd move the bishop because I don't need to unnecessarily push my pawns
And I don't want to move my king. So just move the bishop move the bishop
Let's say to b7 and what's funny is that even if white offers a bishop trade
This is a bit of a trick question because I think it's counterintuitive. Can you take the bishop?
Last time I got asked a trick question. The trick was that there's no trick
Exactly
So, I don't know. I don't I don't know how to trust my coaches anymore. I have trust issues
um, if I take you take
I mean this would look bad, but I guess you would have you take the opposition actually
Yep, so I could just take
Yeah, you take king takes king d7
I can try before to put you in zugzwang, but this f7 pawn is actually on an incredible spot
How would you continue with the black?
Um, take take no, no, that's there we go there's that rule in action
Yeah, we don't oh, we don't push the pawns if we don't need to
We don't push the pawns if we don't need to take is correct
But now a tough move to play I think just intuitively
Which way do you go we have to move the king? Oh
Wait
Okay, so either this way or this way if I come here then you're gonna move the king
Come here, then you're gonna try to come catch this pawn. So then the question is
can I
Take this guy and promote before you could take these guys and promote
Bing so I come here you play here. I play here you play here
bang bang bang
take
King comes here king comes here and then I have one two, three, four five
Oh god, that does not work and not fast enough not fast doesn't work
So then if I come here you come here trying to take this guy
um
How could we possibly promote if I push?
I mean, that's this is way too slow. So that's just that's not it
Which line are you looking at? Sorry king c7 king e5 or are you looking at the other way?
I looked at both and it looks like both don't work, but I could be wrong
No that you're right. The pawn races are all losing for black
But again, yeah, your default is passive defense, right?
Because even when your king is at the most passive spot possible
Sometimes your opponent just can't make progress. So if you look carefully after king c7 king e5
Yeah, what is the sort of?
You know, this is a very difficult move to play
Psychologically, but it draws on the spot
Yeah, ah, the king goes back the king goes back to d7 and after king f6
Oh, this is cool. King f6 tying the pawn. We defend from here
Yep
And then if they push then we just have opposition here
And if the king goes back, then we just we do down his favorite thing and we dance easy clap
Yeah, we follow the king and if white tries to quote-unquote shoulder you here
There is nothing to shoulder because f7 is safely defended by black's king. So how would you
Proceed here with black
Here exactly king, let's say king g8
And just follow we dance we dance and opposition
I think is a pretty overrated concept in a lot of pawn end games where
You cannot assume that just because one side has the opposition you're in zugzwang
That's it's more complicated than that here
As you know, we've just reached the position that uh that we basically started with so black's king shadows white's king
at infinitum
Yeah, these ones are very interesting because it's stuff that like
Based on your intuition you would look at first and you'd be like this to just completely losing
Yeah, because move like this like it just looks like white's way more advanced. You're gonna lose this
But yeah, it's actually interesting because I mean in these scenarios
The only way you could really make the right decision is just through calculation because there's no like
Intuition here. Yeah, and I mean the the big intuitive principle, I think is is the concept of moving unnecessary
But what do you think black played here? And this is a decisive mistake, but it's like it can be very tempting
Yeah, let's see
Probably push one of these guys. She played b5
Yeah
Bad and you're like attacking the bishop
I'm actually very curious how this is losing but i'm guessing because now like the bishop's a weakness
Because I have to stay and defend the pawn. So it's more that you've pushed the pawn on another light square
So if this pawn can be fixed on b5
Then white can approach it with his king
But how do you gain a tempo here with white another very important principle if you have a bishop endgame a knight endgame rook endgame?
You cannot you have to assume that every time a pawn moves the resulting pawn endgame might have a different evaluation
So just because the pawn endgame with the pawn here was a draw doesn't mean that
It's still a draw if the pawn is pushed forward. Oh that
Okay, so we would try to trade the bishops bingo
Uh-huh. In this case the king can get these pawns exactly bishop d5 is a super important move
This gains a tempo because black has to move the bishop back
And now a very strong positional move fixing a pawn and a wick's weak square. Ah b b4
Simply b4 very good. Okay, because it's on the light squares. It's on a light square
Now phase two is to approach the b5 pawn with your pieces, but because you're more active that's much easier to do so black
Has to stay put
Yeah, how would you reshuffle your bishop and your king but be careful?
If you give up territory, you might allow black a fortress. Yep, exactly
If we try to come like this, we could give black this square precisely precisely
um
Ring, ah, this is cool bishop b7
And then maybe then you bring the king this way so that you
Shoulder the king and then you bring this bishop to a6 that is one way to where there's many way
You can bring the bishop back. You can put it on b7. Anyway, um, yeah
On e4 works too. Yeah, but bishop b7. I think it's good enough
The basically king d7 king, uh king d5 c5 and then bishop c6 or a6 is going to end the game
There's nothing to calculate here if black tries this
There's actually a funny line the way you put the b7
Maybe bringing the bishop back is a little bit more accurate. I think
The one way to lose this. No, I think you still win
Oh because the king comes here
And then bishop a8 I think might keep an advantage
Yeah, so it's just more difficult. Well
No. Oh, yeah, because then after bishop b8 you would trade the bishops. Okay. Yeah, it's a little more complicated
Yeah, it's still winning and king b6 you obviously go to the other way, but I think in the game
I don't even have the notation. I think bishop b4 was played and basically just here here and what's the next move going to be?
Bishop d3. Yeah, bishop d3 or bishop c6 you pick up the pawn and the rest is very easy
Yep, the rest is very easy. Nice
Very nice analysis putting on it. Yeah pushing unnecessary pawns in general something that you have to avoid
Um, so let's consider another bishop endgame also from the pcl or 2700. Very good. Very good blitz tips for endgames because I always panic
And push pawns and of course, there's no way to sugarcoat it like by the time you get to an endgame
You're often in a time scramble. There's no way to avoid like a lot of mistakes in the endgame
But developing your intuition does help you, you know
Often avoid stepping on certain landmines and sometimes helps you figure out wins very quickly
So let's consider the following position
All right, I don't know when you see it
It is another I do not same colored bishop. Oh, I see it
All right. This is uh, both sides had a couple of seconds at this point
oh, wow, and
Obviously, it seems self-evident that white is playing for a win right because white is up a point. Yep
But what obstacles could you identify?
In terms of trying to break down black's fortress
Well, their pawns are all on black and white's pawns are in white
So we actually even though we have space our pawns are much easier to attack
Right, so how does that actually hurt white what the it restricts the mobility of what piece the bishop
Right, if let's say white plays some nonchalant move like bishop f3 black will immediately respond with
Bishop b3 taking the pawn bishop b3 and actually white that's the best way to lose right because if you lose a4 you probably lose
the game
Yep
Now white could try white could try to break down the king side with what move this move is useless, but you could try it
Like g6
Well h6 and we're talking from white's perspective. Oh, sorry. Ah, white wants to break down their king side
Yes, but this doesn't help at all. And what you should remember about bishop endgames in particular
Is that if you put your king on the opposite color of your opponent's bishop that is often an insta fortress
Because the king can never be moved from e7
So white literally has no way to make progress here. You literally just shuffle your bishop back and forth and there's no way through
Wait, this is wait
Can you you said the king on the opposite side of the bishop?
What did you mean by that? Yeah, like a king on a dark square if your opponent is a light squared bishop. Oh, you're saying the king
Oh got it. Sorry. Okay, and that allows you same with opposite colored bishop endgames that allows you to build up an immediate blockade
Yeah, this is an easy fortress. The pawns are in black
The king won't be able to enter to attack these pawns and this king's not moving. Gotcha. Exactly
So white concluded that there is no way forward. So white is going to try to break down the king side
The king's not moving. Gotcha. Exactly. So white concluded that there is no way forward and basically repeated moves with king f4 king g5
It turns out that there is a really really cool winning sequence here
That's basically pure tactics
And I think you're able to find this win again
If you force yourself to consider a move that seems to have an obvious refutation
But if you look at that resulting position for a couple of seconds, I think you very quickly spot the follow-up continuation
So what yes move could I be talking about here?
I mean, there's not many options you either bring your king back
Well, I was thinking like should we is it worth calculating if there's any tactics tricks over here?
Also with this bishop g4, but I know we already uh disregarded this move
We disregarded which move
The bishop g4, but I was gonna I was debating calculating stuff just because it looks like maybe if there's a way we could
Kick the king and try to push one of these pawns, but okay, but that was part of the trick, right?
We disregarded it from a general standpoint, but we still need to look
Concretely at the move bishop g4 because that offers a bishop trade which makes sense from a logical perspective
Yep, the pawn end game is obviously lost. So how is black going to respond?
Here and this is the position if you just kind of stare at it for a couple of seconds, you'll find something. Oh
Wait, ah, I think I think I think I should appear
Okay, cuz you take I push king comes here and the king comes here. Oh
Actually, I don't think this works because then you would attack our pawn you can I was thinking yeah
Yeah, you can eliminate the middleman though. Like bishop d7 actually doesn't
Like what you can oh, we don't need that middleman. We don't need that middleman
Oh, we don't need that move, right? Yeah, you just push you push immediately
Why because if black takes then oh, wow
This is very nice. Bishop takes takes takes and now we take this pawn and promote exactly and that's just the beginning. That's step one
so in the game
Why didn't find this but oops. Sorry. Oops, perhaps white even saw bishop g4 and e6
The thing is black is not going to cooperate nor is black going to leave this g7 pawn unattended
Black is gonna step back to f8
Stay on the dark squares and the problem is that if you make the obvious move to me
The obvious move is in g6
Yeah, the problem here is that black is gonna take and it does look winning for white at first you can try what typical motif
push
Yes takes
Takes but where is black gonna put his bishop and why is that gonna be a problem?
Yes here and then what is black gonna do?
Um
Push well, we would have to oh, oh they have a passer. Yeah. Yeah
And we have no way to dislodge the bishop from this diagonal
Yep
And that's the bishop a new promote. Well, I mean, this is really just
Also, yeah. Well, I guess there's no way that this light squared bishop could have stopped this pawn
So that also makes a difference and even if it could you can imagine that what black's king is going to basically
Win this b-pawn because you cannot use your bishop to stop the pawn and defend b5 at the same time
So it's at least a draw got it. It's at least a draw
But same principle applies white has a move here that wins on the spot
And if you look at the position carefully and consider the other candidate moves
It's a tactic and the tactical concept is common in the middle game, but not as common in the end game
Not as common in the end game
Is it h6? It is h6
Yay, this is a nice one
And if g takes h6
And we have deflection here
Simple deflection. Yeah, wait. Yeah, is this not it? That's it. That's it. That's it. Okay. Okay, that's it
Wait, oh
What is the definition of deflection?
Uh, so it could mean several similar things. All right
Right divert a piece from its control over a certain square
Gotcha. Gotcha. Nice. And yeah now that our light squared bishop could attack this square
It's easy
And if they sack we would just take with the king and win this end game
Bingo and just to finish it off bishop takes a4. What's the best move order here?
um the most forcing
Yeah, and it's the only winning move actually here and check because if we started with the bishop then you take the pawn and now
Yeah, now now it's very very easy
exactly
So very nice. So we start with bishop g4. Very nice
Very nice. We consider a position that seems to be pretty much absurd
But once you look at it a little bit more carefully, you can see quickly that you're able to make progress with the movie six
Yep
Um, okay. So let's apply that to a really fun end game a pawn end game
See chat end games can be fun
End games can be fun
Oh
Can be they are
Are fun at all times and we're gonna see the exact same thing in action where?
At first you make a couple of obvious moves and apply an important pawn end game principle
Then you reach a critical position and it's all about forcing yourself to calculate the move that seems to self-evidently not work
There is the starting position
Seveon against lazovic and it's white to play in this position
now
Yeah. Oh, sorry. This is very funny because in these positions
It's fun to play what looks like the worst position in the board when I do it in my blitz games
It just ends into a very tilting downward spiral. So we'll see how this translate into the blitz
Okay
I'll take away the other lessons from this
But no and and I think you'll you'll you'll you'll crack the the secrets of this position pretty quickly. So it's white to play
Okay, um, and I just by the way, I randomly came up with an interesting idea if we do part three
What I might actually do
Is go through your blitz games and sort them and and I can do that on chess space basically
Identify all the end games and we can go over some like instructive mistakes that you made
You're gonna have a lot a lot of oh, yeah
a lot a lot of
A lot to unload there. I don't know if you want to sign up for I like I think there was one time
I even sent oh god my legs. So sorry
She's going off
Uh, there was one time that I sent dina just one blitz games and she just one of mine
She said she had nightmares that night
I would love to do that because I always I have so many like I play so well
And then I just one move one inaccuracy and I throw away everything
So that would actually that would be a really cool youtube video too. I would love that
Yeah, and I think there's nothing like more instructive from like an emotional standpoint than your own mistakes
It's just you learn it hits different honestly when you learn from your own endgame mistakes
So i'll do that for next time. So it's white to play here
and my sort of tip when you get into pawn endgames is
to start with a kind of bird's eye view in the sense that you
You kind of need to forecast what you think is going to happen
That helps you avoid getting overwhelmed because it seems like oh there's a ton of options and I can move my king and I can
Move my pawns, but it's pretty easy to sort through
Uh the wrong moves here if you kind of know where this is going. So, where do you anticipate this endgame going?
How do you anticipate it kind of ending?
Wait the endgame ending what does that mean?
like
What does white want to achieve and what is white likely to achieve and how is black likely to respond to that?
Ah, okay
Well, I would fix this pawn so that your king
Cannot move and then just hope that I block this and it's exactly and we take this guy and black is
Black's only try is going to be to go after what pawn
This h pawn exactly. So you're likely going to get a pawn race between an e pawn and an h pawn and you've already
Identified all the correct moves. How would you start?
e3 go ahead
Black is in zugzwang only one pawn waiting move remaining
and now
H4 is mildly moved and the side that
Is the last to exhaust its waiting move is the winning side because the opposing side is in zugzwang
Yep, so now black has to give up the pawn. Yep. You take the pawn. Oh
I see because I was now the fun begins
Okay, because when I looked at this I was like well
This is losing for white because white has to conquer five squares black has to do four, but you keep the king
Trapped exactly, but the critical moment occurs after king h3. This is the beautiful
Hey, well not specifically. You're sorry. It's on the next move that the cool moment occurs. Wow
Can't so now you basically have only one try to win the game for white
Um, well, of course pushing but I would consider king f3 first
Yeah, but if king f3 then we dance
Yeah, okay. You just go backwards right and you have to repeat moves. You don't ruin anything here. Oh, yeah, nothing happens. Yeah, nothing happens
Yeah, so nothing happens. Yeah, nothing happens
Okay, so we try e4, right?
Now if black plays king g2 and clears the path for the pawn, then it's very easy white plays what?
Um, we push you push and we're careful before you push there's an easier move. Nope. Nope. Nope
Um, ah, we win the pawn
Exactly
Remember with pawn races that it's not you don't have to sort of shut your eyes and push the pawn automatically
You can use your king in many cases
to
Make it as difficult as possible for your opponent to push pawns that allows you to win tempi which in turn
Enables you to win the pawn or sometimes you can simply win the pawn with your king
Okay
So black has to start with the move h4 and this is the critical moment
Sevian went wrong here
Um
Bing bing. Well, I mean there's only two moves you consider this and this this and this exactly
And again, my intuition here
Is misleading like I think if you apply your intuition you come up with the wrong move
My intuition is like this first
King down and now if I do this you go back
I could
I could um push
Then your king would move out of the way. Well, actually no, you would push the pawn
This came with the way we wins the pawn
Um, and then I would do this again to force you down
Yeah. Oh and now the king
Wait
Oof, wait a second. Then I push and then you push and now you're still mating yourself
Move the king then you move the king out of the way
Move the king out of the way then I do this and I bet there's like a sneaky checkmate
Unless you promote to a knight you probably promote to a queen but black promotes first shoot
Your calculation was perfect. No, no you you all the errors are correct, but black promotes first in that line. Yeah
Yeah, and black makes a draw
Yeah, that's not good. We don't want that
We don't want to draw
So let's make the moves on the board so that maybe everybody in the chat could follow what you just calculated. Yes
um, and we are only doing this because we care about the chat and that's because
I want to run for the chess streamer of the year and chat today is about you guys
So this is for you guys. Otherwise, we wouldn't do this. So command vote, please. Okay. All right
So king yeah same with my my stream. I'll link i'll link the streamer awards
And then don't worry dania when you're in the nominations. I will tilt the vote for you
I just have to win this year. I won't care about the next just this year this year
Next year is all about dania
Okay, so king down. All right, then. Um, we follow the king if you do wait frick. No, I fucked up. Okay
That also works. So so king h2
Now let's say we play e5
Yep
Uh, we push
And again, why not king g1 first?
This don't forget about smother the pawn. Exactly very important to remember this in pawn races like
If white pushes then what happens?
um
If white pushes
Then king here and oh, this is what we just looked at so king here
And now if you do this, you just push so it doesn't really matter
So then I push you push
I push and you push with check exactly and black draws the side
It's not just about the side that promotes first in my at a video on pawn races where I talked about like the checking zone
It when you anticipate a pawn race
The first thing you have to identify is if your king is in the checking zone of the pawn
What does that mean?
That means you look at the promotion square of the pawn
And you trace the diagonal that it promotes on and you make sure that your king isn't on that diagonal which here it is
Is there a cool word for this pawn strat you need like, you know, there's a square this this one needs a cool name
I call it the the checking zone of the pawn
Um, we'll take it which is uh, you know, i'm not really known for my originality. I gotta work on the wording
But well, we'll sell it
Yeah, I think it's it's good. It's a good good stand in now if white tries to entrap black's king here
You correctly identified why this is a draw
Um, all right, the king just goes
here
And now he's trapped. So we push and you think that you're gonna get it. But now unfortunately just
two one square too late and he's
In fact, even if it was white to move two squares too late. Yeah
Although it would be winning if it was white to move and you'll see why after we go down the correct line
So as intuitive as king f3 is how do you rule it out intuitively?
Well, it's because first of all, you have to be aware of the stalemate idea
But also king f3 steps into the checking zone of black's h pawn
So you actually end up losing a tempo by making that move. Let's consider the other candidate move
Um
I mean, of course, there's pushing but pushing let's consider that. Okay. Yeah, we'll consider it
This doesn't do anything. Yeah. Okay. Pushing is only move. I was looking at king here, but you just push and it's merely helps black
Push the point, right? Yeah. So this is all you move pushing
Okay, so let's say they do the same thing so they bring the king we do the same thing so they have to push very good
We don't want to try this idea. So let's say we push. Yeah
Um, yeah, i'll try to force myself to calculate and then i'll play it out for the chat. Okay. Um, good call king comes here
And let's say we just go for the push
Then you push
And I push then you push and I promote
And now we're not in the checking zone you promote
It's white to move in that position
Yep
Which gives you some promise? Um, so you could check here. You could check here. I like
Uh, bang bang. Let's see
bang
I mean it looks dry-ish to me
I'm thinking if we check the king here the king has to defend the queen so it'd have to go to g1. Okay
And then we I mean, oh check
King comes here. No, this isn't gonna lead to anything check the king would escape here
Let's make the moves on the board not because you can't visualize but just because there's an important concept that
Is just I think worth worth okay talking over generally and it'll help you seeing the position so promote promote
You can make the moves
And queen so
Sorry, oh, sorry. You wanted to go back. Yeah. Yeah. No promote promote is correct
So there is a concept here, uh a target position where you've pushed black's king to the
Bottom row and then you make a quiet move with your own king and the theme is domination
You dominate the king and the queen with your own king and queen
And the reason that can be hard to figure out is because intuitively you assume
That if it's black's move, they will always have some sort of a check, but that's not always the case
So, how do you push black's king to the first row?
Uh in the most effective way possible, push his king
Force king g1 is the goal
Yeah, well one idea I had was like well if we did this and this and then but the queen down here to trap the
King, but the issues that the queen would escape and check us. So queen e4 also allows king h2. What's the other?
Tempting check here that you could contemplate this check. Yep, and that's just a check
King h2 why not? Oh, it does the job right away. That was and what if king h3?
um
Then check play here and we mate on g3. Bingo. So king g1 is forced and now the crux of the whole position
I was trying to look for something like this
I see I see king g3 interesting. Yeah, I I don't know why I I was I was looking at this concept
But for some reason my brain I could only get there in two moves
But you could just do it right away. Yeah, so king g3 and black's queen is fully dominated
You're threatening a million mates. And if I play chuck
And what do you take? Just be careful not to stalemate him. Yeah, king takes f3 and you went maybe xqc would take the queen
But we on this chat in the best chess streamer chat would take with the game. Absolutely
So that is the kind of target concept here where each of these moves are
So that is the kind of target concept here where even though
Black is forcibly promoting. It doesn't matter because you're using this idea of total domination
nice
um, and this is very very applicable, I think to a lot of different types of end games because
what it allows you to do is figure out a
Exception to a certain rule now, you're familiar. I assume that a corner pawn on the second rank usually draws against a queen
Yes, because
Because of the stalemate ideas. Yes. Now if the white king in this position were to be on a8
Then that would be a draw that concept makes sense
Oh, but because the king's close enough if it's sufficiently close you can use the concept we just talked about to force victory
How would you go about it?
Um like in this position right now? Yes white to play and this position has occurred a million times a specific position I promote
And now we just do what we just transpose. We came in to check king g1
And here and king g3 winning the game. Exactly. Nice
But in the pawn game we considered
You know
You're not supposed to try to block black's king with your king
Because if you look at it concretely it actually turns out to be counterproductive because you step into the checking zone of black's pawn
Wait, you're not supposed to blocks. Oh you mean from the oh, oh
The position that we just looked at like yeah king f3 was wrong in that position, right? Because it gets yeah
So if you chase the king down the file, this is a checking zone. Got it
It's like the tow away zone, you know, have you ever been towed donya? I have been towed once and the story is funny
I was doing a 24 hour stream
Oh, this is back in in stanford. And of course, the only way he would get towed is like doing something wholesome
No, but here's the funny thing. I was doing 24 hour stream
It was my first one and I took a five-minute break to to get some starbucks for obvious reasons
So I went to get starbucks and because I want to stay for as much as possible exactly, right?
So i'm like the minutes are ticking
So on my way back I parked carelessly. I didn't notice where I parked the next morning was saturday morning. I went out
And I don't see my car
And you know that feeling that that's sinking horrible. No, no too. Well this week. Okay, so
I've heard i've heard you're like a father. You're missing your son. You're looking up and down. Where are you?
I don't know what the procedure is where you live, but in the bay area you have to go to the police station
You have to pay like 150 dollars. Then you have to uber to the tow yard. They sent me to the wrong tow yard
Because there were two locations and it's like in the bay area. I mean everything
$600 or something like that. I mean at that the value of my car was less than $600 at a 97
Lexus with 250 000 miles. This is very similar to my honda
So what happened? Uh in your case, sorry to make you relive. Well, no, it was the same story
The cops they lapd stored my honda. I had to uber to the towing zone. I don't know why they towed it
Well, I kind of know why well, I don't really know why honestly it remains a mystery
And it was just a very upsetting feeling went outside looking for my honda
and it was gone California man, I know well now you've escaped it
Yeah, no parking problems here. That's the one
redeeming factor
Uh, don't have to leave 30 minutes earlier. I'll just remember this will be the tow away zone. Yeah. Okay. I like it. I like it
That's what i'm calling it. So, how do you feel you're up for another position? I I know this is like
Conceptually hard so
Um, we can do it. We can do it. We can do it
Okay
So we're going to take a look at a position
um to sort of cap off one of the themes of all these positions, which is that
When you kind of try to think randomly or you try to trust your gut instinct
Often it gets very overwhelming because you're like, you don't know what's going on
It's like this position just seems to be super technical
but a lot of these technical looking positions can actually be deciphered if you think about them very methodically and
You start by making observations you figure out your opponent's defensive ideas and sometimes that leads you directly
To the correct move. I love this position. It's not a famous game at all. It's like 2200 versus 2100
It's white to play
And white has only one only one winning move. Everything else is a draw
And the most obvious move the move that your hand is literally reaching to play with white at least in my case
Leads to a draw. So let's start with that move. What is that incredibly obvious move?
My hand I can't help it
gang a4
So you want to take the pawn and that's it?
But it's not it because black can easily win the c7 pawn how?
And then stop the g-pawn with his king
Bang no, no, not like that. Yeah, just kidding
Yeah, just kidding. The knight will get towed
true
We've got some checks, but that's not it. I mean I would oh
Bang bang and then bang because it restricts the king from defending
Exactly. Alternatively night b6 check at 95 same destination square
And what can white try? Well white can try king b5
but
Now you need to be very careful because if white put instead brings the bishop down take the pawn
Take the knight take is black in the box
Um, bing bing bing pot white pushes. I thought it was a trick, but we are in the box
wait
Yeah, we are
Yeah, b4 king b6 g5 king e6. Yeah, and you're by two temp you're in the box
Yes, but if white tries the tricky move king b5 here a knowledge of theoretical endgames really helps if black tries this move instead
How should black draw this?
um
Bing bing bing bing
Ah, I see. So what would happen is even though we're in the box the king. Yes is in opposition
Yes, so
Let's see. What would we do?
Black would win this pawn and put their king on whites. Excellent. 93. I try the tricky king b6
Yep, and we don't want to let you get this b7 square
So we come to c8 and that's it you take the pawn and you can't stop this
No, and then you return and give your knight away for the last remaining pawn
Then you give your pawn for the last remaining pawn so king a4
This is how the game ended actually white played king a4 this 2200 played king a4
Can't blame him and black drew the game straightforwardly
So, yep. Okay. So what conclusions can we make? Yeah, those those total endgames. How did he find this only winning move?
So what conclusions can we draw from that line?
Well, first of all, we know what black's main defensive concept is and what is the order in which black will do it?
If it was black to move here, how would black go about defending this?
um either
king
I mean just knight here knight here knight d5 knight takes d7. We can't stop that
We can't stop that. We can't restrict them both of the knight's directions
Which my process of elimination gives us only one concept that we could try. What does this concept involve generally?
We can't move our king we can't stop black's knight from winning the c7 pawn so we need to prevent it indirectly
Which means doing what some tough questions that dania is asking today
Hey, I keep thinking I get it and okay indirectly
Stop black indirectly. So not directly so that would be
Got it, just give me one second
And i'm not even looking for one specific move first
I want the general like it involves doing x and then doing y and you can do x in like three or four different ways
I mean
There's only one piece you can do exactly you move the bishop somewhere
Whatever just choose a random make room for the pawn exactly and after black plays knight
Let's say knight b6 to prevent also king c4 white has to try what?
um
Pushing pushing the pawn you have to engineer a situation where the knight is unable to take the pawn
Because the king is no longer in the box
But here's the problem. What is black gonna play?
Uh, well, isn't this they're dry
So it's tricky if we play here and then we do this whole shebang again
Right, then you push we're in the box. So then the only other idea is we are in the no
No, we are in the box. So black is trying to draw. So that's the correct move
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, right. Yeah. Yeah, you are in the box as black. Yeah now the bishop hangs
Make a mental note of that. That's very important the bishop hangs. It has to waste the tempo and now
And now we trade and we are in the box. Damn it. Yeah by one tempo now, right not by two tempi by one tempo
Yeah, so why is black in the box? Well, it's because black gained the tempo on the bishop move
So now we modify the idea such that there is no tempo move by the night
And logically there's only one square that the bishop could move to to make that happen
Here
Excellent bishop h2 because we tried bishop f4, right?
Yeah, but if you play bishop e5
If you play bishop e5, how is black going to draw this?
Um, well, I don't think king here actually does anything because so here there's yeah, then we move back here
There's a really cool knight maneuver. So you do play knight e7
Yep, white plays g4 if black plays knight d5 then white wins with what move?
um
push push
Take push
But black can make a different tempo move and get the knight around to e6 if black gets the knight to e6
Then you stop g5 and threaten knight takes c7 simultaneously. How does black do that?
Oh, you attack the bishop and then you have check and then you can exactly knight c6 bishop moves check here here
And on the next move you take the pawn and you are still in the box
So the only winning move is bishop to h2. It's a lot. So how does this work? Let me try to defend this
You'll win this with black. I have to start the process with the knight
Okay, we would continue our plan push the pawn push time push time
Now you attack
And then I push push time knight takes c7 now loses doesn't work and finally you've broken the defense
Well, I have to go back to e7
But now we casually win this game by doing what now it's finally time to do what we wanted to start
We continue the plan. I take this pawn. We take this pawn. So black has to shuffle black is totally paralyzed
He is paralyzed. Yes. So let's say knight g6 and what's the actual final phase of the winning plan? How do we actually?
end this game
Uh, how do we end him? Ah
No
bing bing
um
Well, my first idea was oh we
Trapped the knight and the knight would come here. Maybe there's a sukspong. Oh, we don't even need to we have a more straightforward plan
Now remember you just bring the king
We bring the king don't try to dislodge the king from c8 because obviously that's not possible physically
Yeah, which means we need to keep the bishop anchored to the pawn
And just use our king to dislodge the knight. The knight is extremely restricted in and how it's able to defend
So just get your king. Yep
Okay, so we just bring the king over here. Yeah to do 97
And just avoid the checks avoid all forks. Yeah, but there aren't even any forks. Yeah, but
King b7 king d7 so black is almost already in sukspong
Here, okay. Let's say here
here
and
um now
We don't do something silly
Why?
Wait, this is good. Yeah. Yeah
Yeah, for some reason I thought yeah. No, yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, we push and we win
The only condition under which it's drawn as you know is when the corner pawn of the wrong color
Every other such end game is winning
Um because you're just shoulder blacks king away, right?
Yes principles. Yes, and that is the winning process. Let me summarize. Um, very good you spotted bishop h2
Uh very quickly. So the point is first of all, you reject the obvious move
That helps you understand what black's defensive strategy is which is essentially just to take c7 with the knight
Then you say well
I have to make sure that the king is not going to be in the box
After that happens that means you have no time to waste and you have to move the bishop and then
Move the pawn forward but you have to move the bishop in such a way that the knight is not able to gain a tempo
On route to winning the c7 pawn and logically bishop h2 keeps the bishop furthest away from the knight
So it's the only winning move. Everything else is a draw and they say chess is hard. It's easy like that
Simple very simple. What could be more straightforward than this end game? Really? I mean, yeah, no, it's very
Intuitional and yeah, very natural who would ever miss. I love chess. Who would ever miss the both?
Who would ever miss the both? I'm sure if I was a 2200 I would see this I had um, we can pause here for today
I had there was one more position I had prepared in case
Uh, you're up for it or we can uh save it for next then. What how do you how do you feel?
Uh, whatever you're feeling donya
I'm, I can do one more if you're good with it. We can do one more
I would just need a a bathroom break, please teacher
You never drink any water. Is it because you're a robot? No. No, I have like two beverages on my desk
soda
Those are not good for you. No soda. No, this is sparkling water
I I almost never drink I love soda like I love root beer and stuff, but I almost never do it
And iced tea is like my probably my biggest beverage of choice
Those are the top grandmaster drinks the top and usually coffee, but I haven't I haven't had coffee a couple days actually
a couple days actually a couple days
I'm on a reset you've been through some dark times. Yeah, literally no pun intended with coffee
All right. Okay, so
There are some crazy mind-blowing positions that we'll we'll save for next time. This one I think is manageable
It is okay. Obviously it is black to move
And your goal is very obvious. You have to decide between two possible moves
What are they? Okay?
Either King e5 or King e7 King e5 or King e7 which way should black go?
I'll let you think about it one move loses one move
Gives black a draw
Okay
One loses, okay
Okay, crazy idea, but the only forcing move that this the only first move that I consider here
Is d4 because the pawn would have to take then I would take the rook then the king would take
And then king would come to e3 tying this pawn and this king. Oh, wait
Yes, it can defend the pawn then the king would just come there defending the pawn
But I feel like there's some crazy suksvang
here
Because we would push this pawn
Let's say you I would have to do some counting here, but like you push you push
Oh, I think we need to push it once good, but like we would put them in suksvang and win this pawn
Oh god, okay. Yeah. Yeah
I don't know you're saying all the right things
It leads somewhere it leads somewhere and then we would take the pawn
I I can see it ends like with the pawns here. These guys are blocked. We take this guy and the king's here
So it really depends if we have the tempo or not. So two things
Um, first of all, you're absolutely correct that d4 check is the move which has to be considered
But the point of this move isn't really to put black in suksvang
What you should understand about this resulting pawn endgame
It's winning but it doesn't matter even if white can cause suksvang
What you should notice here is which side has the outside pass pawn?
I see white is the outside passer, but there's a second thing you when you're trying to create a pass pawn
You have to be extremely careful about allowing your pawn stick to be deep frozen
So which pawn would you start with? How do you actually create the passer on the queen's side?
With the b pawn, why not a4?
A4 you push a5. Yes. So this is what you have to avoid
The rule is usually to push the perspective of passer
So you identify which pawn is ultimately going to be the passer
Well, it's obviously the b pawn because both sides have an a pawn
So you push the pass pawn first that guarantees that you won't be caught in the middle
That guarantees that you won't be caught in a deep freeze
Got it. Go ahead
Um, uh, wait, what what do you mean?
So which move would white play here?
Oh, you can make moves
Oh, oh, sorry. So in this position you mean this one?
Yeah, let's say black pushes
And the crucial bit is that it doesn't even matter how many waiting moves black has
It's not about suksvang
It's about the fact that you are going to create that passer and force black's king
To abandon all of the king's side pawns. Continue
Um, I don't think it matters here if you push a4 or b5
So either work
b5 is I would say even more clinical. Yeah
And now I bring this guy in
And obviously this pawn race f4 takes takes a5 is just easily winning for white
Black is not even close
So that's it. I mean, let's say I go king e6
Take king d6
That's it. The game is over. King e6
Actually here you don't even need to deflect black's king. You can just straight up promote
Yeah
b6 ab
Ah, no, even simpler. Yeah, no, no a6 outside pass pawns
Outside but a b also wins, right? This is important to understand because here you
Very simple winning plan
Deflection
So in pawn endgames the outside pass pawn is probably the single most important thing to identify or the potential to create one
Because okay, ironically black is the side that has two pass pawns white has zero pass pawns
But it's still winning and you should determine that intuitively because you should sense that white
Will inevitably create the pass pawn on the side of the board
Okay, and that is exactly how black lost the game. We're talking about a 20
2057 fide
So not you know some juicy fide rating amateur off the street
So actual strong players make these mistakes. Now. Why did he reject king e7 intuitively?
Well, what's the reason that king e7 doesn't seem appealing? Well, first you're blundering the pawn with check
Yep with check if it wasn't check you'd be able to go rook f2 and rook takes h2
But just because you're a pawn down doesn't mean the game is over
In fact, this is an easy draw because black is threatening to infiltrate, right?
Yep, and if white tries to stop here, there is a very important defensive motif
Where you just check him infinitely and white's king cannot cover all of the infiltration squares
Oh, you just keep going back and you're going back and forth and if white's king
Go ahead
And if white's king runs to g4
Then we come behind the pawn. Yeah, your rook gets active you take b2
And even though you're a pawn down it's a draw because black is super active and can create a second pass
So this is pretty easy easy draw to make white can't even move his king because the h2 pawn is going to be lost
Yep, and if the king tried to go to like g1 then i'm guessing then the square that we want to control is the e2 square
Bingo, exactly. You always go back
Yeah, and last thing i'll point out here is let's say white goes for k5 you can also play rookie too
But one technique you should be aware of is to basically go behind the pawn in order to be able to capture it with check
Oh
interesting
So that's uh
Rookie two. Yeah, which also should draw. So rookie two draws with a with I think a similar motif
What should black do here?
um
As my coach would say always give a check in the end game. It's like
Almost always going to be a good thing
You would just do the same thing just but not here not here. There's a better move. No, no
We have this. Oh, oh check first and then take the sky and then take the pot and if white goes the other way
Uh this way then you take this guy. Yeah, you take b2 and you're threatening checkmate
You gained it
So this is better than taking right away just because we gain one tempo and that one tempo makes the difference
Yeah, because you're threatening you're threatening me
Yeah
So white has to respond to that either by bringing the rook down and now I would say like white is the one defending
Or yeah, if king g2 what's hilarious is you do the same thing again and white could lose this way
Because like now you take a2 and again, you're threatening the rook
Got it. But and if you didn't check is it still a draw? If you don't give the check where
Uh, like if we just take right away, so here instead of checking what I guess you're losing the spawn
So that's why it's probably still a draw. Yeah, the end the engine gives zero complicated
But no even even you could take the spawn immediately because the reality is
Even if you play I think rook to d2
You don't get a check
The reality is even if you play I think rook to d2 usually and you probably know this two on ones with rooks are
Usually draws unless the pawn is super far advanced or something
Yes
Unless the pawn is super far advanced. It's it's generally speaking a draw
Yeah, i'm not very good at these end games neither. I mean, I don't think anybody is this is like always hard to defend
So you should try to avoid this scenario impossible
But just so you know, like even if you do quote-unquote all the wrong things, it's still a draw
You'd be surprised you'd be surprised in my blitz games, but that'll be for next stream
I lost i've lost a lot of these types of end games. So
Yeah, I struggle with you. Don't worry
yeah, so obviously I have tons of positions and
Uh, we could you know go between tactics and and conceptual positions, but I think ultimately
The biggest misconception with end game improvement not that I know is probably against my weakest point
Is that there are all of these concepts that are applicable in rook end games, you know
Keep your rook behind the pawn and most of you already know so at this point in your chess development
I think a lot of it is literally just
Treating end games the same way that you treat tactics and just solving a crap ton of different positions
Because pattern recognition in the end game is much more
More important of a concept than I think people realize people think it's all concepts
but really a lot of end game mastery is just
Recognizing patterns just like you do when let's say you solve chess.com puzzles
Got it. So approaching them like puzzles approaching them like puzzles and appreciating the role of tactics and calculation in the end game
Which is what we've kind of focused on the first two times
So very nice. It's tough. It's a grind. That's why i'm gonna steal that and use that for my youtube intro
So absolutely please do please do
Okay. Well, I will release you from the torture andrea, but this is super super fun. I hope you know positions weren't too
Crazy, no, these are always great. I I do like these
They were the last two were quite crazy, but they all make sense
And you pitch them in a fun way, which I didn't think you could do. So this is good
I appreciate that and you know, as long as you understand the logic, uh behind the solution and can derive like any sort of general
Uh lesson whether it's a pattern that you now know or a certain type of idea like here for example, right the concept of
Sacking a pawn to change the pawn structure is really important to create the outside pawn
Yeah, so yes these small lessons they add up when you solve a thousand positions
You'll start recognizing these patterns in your games and definitely i've got a lot more fun positions
So i'd always be down for part three
But I think good good spot to call it a day for now
Thank you so much. Tanya. Are you gonna continue streaming? I'll stream for a bit. Yeah
Okay, sounds good. We'll see if we finish before you I probably i'll probably take a break
So i'll actually i'll probably end the stream and radio and then but i'll definitely be back tonight
You're very funny. You always do two streams in one day. You should just put on like an internal starting soon sign
Yeah, we do we'll be back for like an hour about that
Yeah, yeah, they won't know
No one will know. All right, but thank you. It's a it's a pleasure. You're you know, you're awesome
Your community is awesome. So i'm always happy to do this and
Looking forward to it's a part three
Sounds good. I'll put in my votes
Okay, please do it's very important. We need your vote. We need it. Every vote counts. Donnie. You got it
I'll send you the raid pretty soon
Okay. Thank you. Dania. Have a good century. You too. Great session. Bye